uh we have one little scheduling change
uh it has been up to have on the website
so uh it was going to be the second talk
in the afternoon wasn't feeling well so
we stopped him with Aaron Wagner who was
in a different room working on his talk
so so that'll be the second talk uh
after one so first our first speaker is
Highland young I have new csb which
doesn't mean nothing about fairness
without imputation take it away
thanks everyone for uh not missing my
talk about missing values
um I know it's hard to stay focused uh
after lunch so I'll try to keep it
light-hearted as much as I can
so we live in an interesting time
and maybe that's an understatement we
live in a freaking exciting time
how many of you have watched uh the
South Park episode on chat GPT
it's also written by Chester PT
not many of you well to be honest it's
not one of the funniest episodes I have
but I think it's still worth it to watch
it because it's like Monumental because
you know you really made it when you
have a whole South Park episode
dedicated to you right
and um how many of you have students who
submit their homework listing chat GPT
as a collaborator
okay I have I see one hand
exactly at this point you should not
question your students are honesty uh so
like this was the actual homework guy in
my class it was like homework one it was
like a math review kind of homework uh
so I asked them to type their uh answers
in latex and this very honest student
told me that uh she's not familiar with
latex so she used chapter to get help
with the latex part and she submitted
the perfect homework she's a great
student she's actually not working with
me on very interesting problem related
to generative AI
um so we live in this time for this
exciting AI Technologies are coming out
that's gonna change permanently how we
work or how we create
and I think we are all gathered here
today because we are kind of people who
thought about different kinds of failure
modes of these AI Technologies I mean
these Technologies are awesome like
mind-blowing me awesome but they're
still not perfect they still have
different kinds of failure modes and
we've been thinking about whether they
can fail to protect people's privacy or
whether they fail to perform safely and
robustly in different kinds of
environments and so on
and one of that's failure modes um which
is now well known in the community is
unfair performance of predictive models
so when we trained a machine learning
model algorithm for criminal justice it
was biased against black criminals and
when we used a machine learning based ad
recommendation algorithm it was showing
different ads for different genders and
different races and there were many
facial recognition algorithms that work
really well on white guys but not as
well on other demographic groups
and in this talk I want to introduce you
to a different kind of failure mode
maybe you haven't thought as much about
which is
unfair performance in data
pre-processing especially uh
pre-processing missing values
so missing values are simply missing
entries in your data set and in real
world data sets they're really
everywhere
for instance in survey data there can be
a lot of missing entries because people
don't answer all of the questions
because they don't feel comfortable
answering all the questions where
they're just feeling lazy to answer all
the questions and electronic health
records notoriously have a lot of
missing values because each row of the
table is a record of one person and not
every individual takes the same set of
medical tests so if you if an individual
doesn't take certain medical tests those
entries are left empty and also in
police reports uh when police officers
are filing for crime reports they don't
fill in all of the details so a lot of
entries are left empty
and one interesting observation uh I
made when I was working with uh this
High School Long Distance longitudinal
study data set is that this data missing
pattern is not independent of sensitive
group attribute like race or a gender so
I'm just showing three example variables
here
um and then I'm showing a missing rate
for different uh races so I'm showing
missing rates for white and Asian
students and missing weights were black
Hispanic and Native American students so
you can see that for all of these
variables missing rate is substantially
higher uh in black Hispanic and Native
American students
for some variables like secondary
caregivers highest education is as high
as the difference is as high as 15
percent
and then we train a machine learning
model on the trading data that have this
kind of disparate missing patterns and
then we use the machine learning models
to make decisions on individuals that
can have like significant impact on
people such as we can make education
related decision whether to give an
admission to this person or not or we
can make very important medical
decisions or like failed decisions in
criminal justice
so now the question uh I'm asking is
then can we still train a fair model
after pre-processing this this very
missing patterns that exist across
different uh demographic groups
this question clear
so uh when I asked when I post this
question uh I think uh the first
question I get is how do you even Define
a fair or a fairness and I assume that
this audience is pretty familiar with
fairness metrics but I'm gonna just give
you a brief uh review
so I am gonna consider a group fairness
metrics and for this we are looking at
performance metrics uh per groups and in
this case I'm going to consider binary
groups for Simplicity so f equals zero
is a minority group and S equals one is
majority group
um and then again for Simplicity we're
going to assume that we are giving a
binary prediction y hat and then the
basic concept of group finished metrics
is that performance metrics of machine
learning models should not depend on
this kind of sensitive group attribute
so depending on how we measure the
performance of machine learning model
there are different types of group
fairness metrics when we care about
equalizing positive rate which is
probability of Y hat uh being one then
uh that
group various metric is statistical
parity and when we want false negative
rate between two groups to be equal then
that Advantage match group and its
metric is equalized opportunity and when
we want to have equal accuracy across
two groups that's an accuracy parity
and in the ideal word we want the gaps
in these metrics to be exactly zero but
that's not always possible so what we do
is we take the group wise difference for
these metrics and we want to make uh the
difference as small as possible
so as I mentioned
um this unfairness in predictive models
that has been studied a lot in the
literature so people have looked at how
to design more fair algorithms when we
train a predictive when you train a
predictive model here so we we basically
what we are trying to do is we want to
reduce these differences when we are
training a model
so then the problem is when uh
researchers uh develop or evaluate these
new Fair models they usually use a clean
and curated data that don't contain any
missing values however in real word most
data sets are not as clean uh they have
a lot of missing entries and we have to
do a lot of data cleaning so
there's a long day of pre-processing
Step that comes before actually training
a model and people even say that
data scientists time is spent 90 on data
cleaning not actually training a model
so the question is then what about
fairness issues that could arise here
a lot of people say that oh machine
learning models are biased because the
data is biased but then if we
are not careful about our data
pre-processing steps can we actually
introduce more bias in the data that
will harm the predictive model we're
going to drain later
and especially what we care about is
pre-processing missing values so let's
see what exactly happens in the data
pre-processing step so when there are
missing values you can either drop
entries that have missing values or you
can do something called data imputation
and usually data imputation is a much
better way for a better performance when
you have a sufficient number of missing
entries so data invitation is basically
filling in missing entry with a new
value it could be mean imputation you
take the mean of the column and impute
that value or it could be median
imputation or you can do something more
sophisticated like K and an imputation
or a multiple imputation and so on
and
learning with missing values dealing
with missing values is a classical
problem people have looked at this
problem for decades and learning Fair
models that have been a very active area
of research in the past five ten years
however these together fairness in
imputation that hasn't gained a lot of
attention from from the community in
fact uh when we thought about this
problem we only found two previous work
uh Fernando at all and one and thing at
all and they mostly did empirical study
on how different amputation methods can
affect Pyrenees metrics they care about
but we wanted to and there are some more
works that came after our work were
around the same time
and
our work ask some more fundamental
questions and the question we're asking
is is it sufficient to do data
imputation first and then apply a fair
learning algorithm on the imputed data
so the meal I will write a little bit
more on this so if we take all the steps
that come before data training as a
black box and then we take you know
state of the art fair learning algorithm
here and then training of their model
here it's just sufficient to guarantee
good fairness in the final model
should be a fair learning model mean
because my learning model is actually
learned on that data setting as much to
that data set so I mean the data set
cannot be a black box today
or I mean sure you can have data
processing that could be a Blackboard
if you pick a parametric that has to be
with
it and so you design a fair algorithm
it's for this data set right
okay I think that a fair point so you
will design a fair learning algorithm or
take
Care Learning argument that works well
for this particular data set
um and then you have only a view of this
data set after it got pre-processed so I
think you're right that it's not data
set itself is not black box but then the
steps that come before this data set is
a black box so yeah
but I'm not talking about the data set
we are talking about the distribution
right so the data set is to replace the
distribution but it's not it's not equal
to one
right right
did you find the fairness because you
find in respect to the underlying
distribution not the underlying data
but
the other you make that assumption from
unless you're making some assumptions on
the distribution sure sure but the the
fundamentally the third the metric the
paradise metric
is it's a function of the model and the
distribution
the data set is just prints to the end
I'm serious
sorry keep going okay any other
questions
um okay so I think the question is clear
now
um and uh so towards answering this
question
um we first did a theoretical analysis
that analyzes different risks of this
disjoint process of data imputation and
model training and each theorem shows
different uh kind of risks and I'm gonna
go more into details of each theorem
soon but let me just highlight The Last
Theorem The Last Theorem is an
impossibility result that shows that
there is no universally Fair imputation
method for different Downstream learning
tasks so if we want to learn different
models that's the logistic regression or
neural network then
um one imputation method might not be
sufficient to perform well for both of
those models so this kind of inspires us
to develop a more integrated approach
between imputation and uh and learning
so that's our second part of
contribution so we propose this
algorithm called Fair MIP Forest which
integrates uh this processing of missing
values and fair learning into one
algorithm
and then we show through experiments
that uh this approach variant might be
first approach uh achieves better
fairness accuracy trade-offs if you
don't understand these graphs don't
worry about it I'll get back to it later
so let's uh go a little bit more into
our theoretical analysis
so the first risk is showing that the
performance of imputation method itself
can be biased
so we have data set with missing values
X tilde and then we do the imputation
and fill this in and then we in in this
part we quantify the performance of
imputation method using L2 Norm so if
this data set has missing entries we
compare the impurity value and the
original data and then get the expected
L2 loss and then what we care about is
the group wise difference in this
imputation performance
and what we show is the following
so let me break this theorem down a
little bit so we first make uh
simplifying assumptions that um data are
missing completely at random which is a
common assumption that is made in the
learning with missing values literature
and we also make another simplifying
assumption that um the setup observed
variables is an empty stack and then we
show that the imputation performance gap
between group 0 and Group 1 is upward
bounded by this term
which consists of missing rate
difference between two groups and mean
difference between two groups and
variance difference between two groups
so if
group 0 and Group 1 have identical
distribution then there won't be any Gap
in imputation performance but that's
usually not the case and when there is
some difference uh in the data
distribution for Group 1 and group 0 and
also a missing rate difference and this
is the upper bound of the imputation
performance Gap it could have
and then the second theorem shows the
risk of mismatched imputation methods so
let me uh explain a little bit more
about what that means so let's say an
entity trains a model uh on the data
that have a lot of missing values so
they have to use some kind of data
imputation technique when they're
training the model but when they're
releasing their trading model to their
clients let's say then they might not be
able to disclose their imputation method
in all details maybe they they were just
lazy about it they didn't disclose all
the details or in some cases they're
just not able because
disclosing all of this imputation
algorithm could actually leak some you
know privacy let's say they use a mean
imputation and um you know giving a lot
of mean information can violate
differential privacy so when a client
gets this trained model and applies uh
this model on their testing data they
might have to choose their own
imputation method which might not
exactly match the imputation method that
was used during the training time
so when there's this mismatch between uh
training time imputation method and
um testing time imputation method now we
are measuring again group wise laws or
group group s
and then this is we apply inputation
first and then we apply this trend
classifier and we want to
quantify the gap between two groups of
this metric
and then what we show is that again we
show an upper bound that testing Time
Performance is upper bounded by training
Time Performance Gap plus this term
which is uh distribution shift caused by
mismatch imputation which is measured
with a total variation uh distance but
again this is um upper bound we are not
saying that whenever there is a mismatch
imputation method we are going to have a
larger bias what we are saying is that
because of the mismatched imputation
methods the fairness constraint will be
imposed during training time may not
guarantee fairness during testing time
so we we have to have that in our mind
and The Last Theorem is uh saying that
imputation without being aware of the
downstream task is somehow fundamentally
sub-optimal
so uh to state this theorem let me just
introduce a few more notations so a lot
of fairness intervention methods can be
thought of as constrained optimization
problem so we are doing a user
optimization here but then we have this
constraint so we have this different
loss function little L and we want to
make sure that this loss function is
similar between group 0 and group one so
it's bounded by small number Epsilon
and when we use imputed data everything
goes through the same but we are first
doing invitation and then applying this
classifier H and then we want to make
sure that everything works uh the same
way even uh with this additional process
of imputation
and then the question here is is there
a universally good imputation method of
imp
that can guarantee fairness which is
given by this constraint and accuracy
which is given by this loss function for
any model class uh age
and then so
um again to show it with the more
Graphics is there any good imputation
method here that could have you know
good fairness and good accuracy for two
different kinds of machine learning
models and we show that that is not
possible we show a simple counter
example that's showing that this is not
possible
so inspired by these risks of disjoint
process of data imputation and training
we proposed a fair MIP porous algorithm
and let me tell you a little bit more
about how fair MIP 4S algorithm works
Okay so
this very my people's algorithm
combines two existing ideas first one is
visiting an attribute and then the
second idea is fair decision trees
so decision trees have a very natural
way of dealing with missing values so we
don't always have to do Data imputation
before training a decision tree and that
is by using this idea of missing an
attribute so instead of filling in all
of the missing entries we can leave
those missing entries as they are and
then uh when we are splitting at each
node when we are let's say we are
splitting on feature two at this node
then we just check we just have one more
check whether feature two is missing or
not so in this case temperature 2 is
missing we are sending all of those
entries to the left and then for those
entries that are not missing that we are
doing the regular dysentery splitting uh
with a threshold 1.5 and we do something
similar here at this node uh when
feature zero is not missing it goes uh
now it's um
following this threshold and then
picture zero is missing it's going to go
to the right and so on
so now
um we don't have to do imputation using
this idea missing it in attribute so
that problem is solved and then the next
question is then how do we impose a
fairness constraint we care about such
as statistical parity or equalizer so
for that we use this idea of fair
decision tree proposed by a gay era in
2019 so they formulate
training a decision tree as a mixed
integer program and formulating decision
tree training as an extension program
it's not a new idea it's been done
before but they add uh this fairness
constraint to to to the objective
function and the reason why we want this
mix into the program is because the user
way of training a decision tree is a
greedy algorithm where at each node we
are maximizing or minimizing some kind
of objective but then we can't really
guarantee that we are minimizing a very
explicit loss function so to have this
explicit loss function with the fairness
regularizer we're going to use integer
programming approach
so there's a lot of notations here but
you don't really have to worry about any
of this uh so really what you have to
know is the objective function there's
explicit loss function which consists of
the regular loss part part and then
vanish regularizer part and this parent
is regularizer part can represent all
the fairness metrics I mentioned like
the parity equalizers and accuracy
parity and then we have these variables
these are binary variables so now
splitting at each node in a decision
tree uh just becomes binary variables in
in this integer program
but when when they formulated this a
fair decent tree algorithm they didn't
really think about missing values
um in in the training data so we add
this additional variable M which denotes
the data missingness and then we
incorporate this idea into the the MIP
formulation and everything worked out
but one uh concern you might have now is
that into the program is very
computationally expensive does it make
sense to do integer programming so it is
actually it takes hours to just train
small decision tree using integer
program so what we did is we just train
uh each tree with the given step amount
of time let's say 30 seconds or one
minute but then we take an ensemble of
those trees and um we observed that
there's having an ensemble of these
three things let's say 23s perform so
much better than one tree that was like
optimized for hours
so that's where the forest part comes in
all right so now we have this algorithm
so we wanted to do some numerical uh
benchmarking of this algorithm so the
goal is to compare the disjoint process
of doing imputation first and then
applying a fair loading algorithm uh and
our proposed very MIP for rest and to do
this we use um two very commonly used
dataset compass and adults and high
school longitudinal study data set which
really motivated this project
and then for the fair learning algorithm
we have three different benchmarks this
very mistreatment reductions approach
and equalize all the post-processing and
for imputation method uh we tried Main
imputation and knutation
and let's look at the result
so for compass
uh the for both compass and uh high
school and student study data set a
y-axis is accuracy and uh x-axis is
group wise difference in false negative
race so we want this difference to be as
small as possible so uh being on the
left side on the x-axis is a good thing
and we want accuracy to be as high as
possible so we
what we want is a high curve as possible
which shows the best fairness accuracy
trade-off
and then these circles our main
imputation and these squares are K and
an imputation and for all different
kinds of combinations of mean imputation
canine imputation and different uh Fair
learning methods we can see that this
integrated approach using Fair MIP
Forest has the best fairness accuracy
trade-off
so I think I have enough time so again
as I mentioned uh in the beginning this
problem of looking at fairness and
missing values or fairness in data
pre-processing I think is largely
unexplored area
uh for instance what we did in this work
is integrating imputation methods into
the learning algorithm and making it as
like one process
but in some cases you will have to do
data imputations let's say you are like
the entity who's collecting the data and
when you're releasing your data you
might have to do data imputation and
release the complete data for your
clients
so there are situations where imputation
during imputation is unavoidable then
can we at least make sure that this
imputation method has some kind of
fairness guarantee and can we design a
fair amputation method I think this is
really largely an open question and then
uh in this work we really focus on using
decision trees and this nice property of
missing an attribute to integrate
imputation into learning but can we do
the same thing for other machine
learning models like neural networks
um and I think our call authors Flavio
and how have been working on this
problem and been extending this to other
clusters of models like linear models
um and I think this problem is
Soma fundamentally information theoretic
problem because missing values is
basically
um going through these eraser channels
and we've been thinking about having
these erasers and reconstructing it
using error particles for a long time
and can we borrow those information
theoretic insights to solve this problem
so I think that's an exciting Direction
but um missing values is again not the
only step in data pre-processing stage
there are many other steps like data
balancing and data encoding let's say
you have a mix of real valued entries
and like text entries then you would
have to somehow convert the text entries
into real valid number using maybe text
embedding techniques and so on and could
they actually bring in more biases in
the data when it comes to the model
training stage and I have some
undergraduate students at UCSB working
on this question and I think there's a
lot of interesting questions we can
address here and uh thanks for your
attention
so implicitly a tree is building the
empirical statistics of the data to
learn it
so by allowing for this missing you're
sort of
explicitly taking care of the statistics
of the missing data in some sense right
so is that how you get and then
explicitly writing that out into your
fairness requirements is that the key
intuition in getting these of getting in
so if you go back to that AP
longitudinal data do you see uh
something change I mean I know you
showed us some results but
I'm trying to make a connection from
here to like what does it mean to be
fair when there is missing data like
you don't really know that data point
but are you
yeah so I I think you're absolutely
correct that so by by training training
this tree we're basically doing we're
not doing invitations but somehow we are
doing implicit imputation because by
saying only together it's like going
that way or that way
um so we are doing some kind of
imputation but this is not imputing just
one value you can think of it as doing
um if assigning a range of values
um
and um and then
so the question is so this is just say
demographic parody Or statistical part
um how does this help
s yes
okay so
um
I think one way to think about this is
when you do imputation
um and then you optimize something for
imputation and then you apply Fair
learning algorithm which you can think
of it as like constraint optimization
algorithm right and then now we are kind
of thinking about this whole thing as
one constrained optimization problem so
it's always better to have this one
constraint optimization problem than
having like two you know optimization
problems separately
um
foreign
making this m car assumption which is
missing complete completely at random
but for uh experiments we are not making
uh any assumptions like that so for high
school longitudinal study data set we
are not making any artificial missing
values but data set itself already has
missing values and uses processing that
position if they're uh Missing at random
but there is a correlation with
um
yeah so that's a that's a good point so
it's missing completely at random per
group but yeah so for those theoretical
answer that's just what we assumed and
then for experiments we've been asking
anything
maybe related to the Assumption can you
go back to your slide where you have the
theorem so there was a second assumption
and
afraid of misery
oh yes yes
yeah so that
so that question so um again like in
this case like we're
a really simple kind of exam
type thing and then uh here
um
so what this means is that let's say you
have a data point of two dimensions
then when the data is missing then both
entries are missing so it's either You
observe both of them or nothing I should
see you you erase the entry yeah
basically yeah
so the entire row is gone is that what
that means entire row is going to accept
accept a sensitive attribute
yeah
so it makes sense if you think about I
think mini education so uh when we when
we get the best invitation method here
for minimizing l-tuno uh imputation
method will be the best one really mean
imputation and then when you take the
mean then uh
because the distributions are different
now you have gaps in performance yes in
the sun theorem 3 correctly it says for
any amputation method there exists H1 H2
model classes for which if it's if you
achieve accuracy and fairness for each
one you cannot achieve all four times
so we can say that for any like H1 and
H2 if this imputation method performs
well on H1 it won't perform on H2 but in
what we are saying is there exists H1
and H2 and is it is it that these H1 H2
are reasonable or uh like can we say
that exists because for example if H
minus two are single single solves
um maybe that's not very practical like
in Practical situations H1 is too
original can we say that there exists
reaching of H1 and H2 to which
uh this also happens
okay so we have thought about reaching
up H1 and H2 and again when we are
improving this theorem uh
very simple counter example I think H1
was just using one feature for uh
classification and H2 is like using the
second feature for classification
um and then showing that um one
application method cannot work well for
H1 and H2
um but I think that's a great question
okay great thank you very much
[Applause]
sub is
very graciously